what we could cut all that out we just
came back from martial rug gallery and
we'll do it again you know he's saying
that
when you go to his podcast your podcast
is one of the slickest most amazingly
produced podcasts i've ever seen there's
animation there's
he'll put a hat on you when there isn't
a hat there's these little goblins
[Laughter]
all right lou one for 87. is it 15
minutes he said amazing it's not 15
minutes
do i have to restart it
i feel like i feel like this is a note
from production
it just makes it easier but i'm just
saying like it was amazing the first
time i was on you made me have like this
huge penis well no that's just genetics
but we did do a beanstalk shout out to
tom bates by the way who animates with
me not for me not with me but it's it's
amazing the music and the animation and
the editing and then i come back here
and you're just sitting on a couch
talking to me and we do absolutely
nothing yeah
rich
i'm saving money you're spending all
your money on animation well you have a
hologram machine that's [ __ ]
you don't use any of this stuff i'm not
even here usually i'm at home this is a
hologram you spend your money on stuff
that nobody sees
which i guess is kind of cool i am
wearing expensive underpants
um
did you sponsor the podcast no
no we did have a the underpants we once
when we started well i have no sponsors
now you have sponsors i know you and
your dad read and you really don't have
ads no none you swear to god yeah why
i don't want him
wow
do you want to advertise your podcast on
mine yeah but like
officially yeah and pay me for it i
don't even have to pay you
okay
um
i don't want i don't want to no it's
just because then i'll make money and
then there's taxes i just don't want no
the truth is when we started we had we
were normal and we had a company came to
us that was distributing this podcast
and they had ads and we had to do ad
reads
and eventually what i'd like to do is
build the audience i'm finding my way
this is just finding my way it is very
this episode is very different than the
episode we started with and in two
months from now
this may not you seem to have found your
groove but you're
they're not advertising
a certain format they're just
advertising on your show to your own
right so we would get notes you know to
go oh how we make this more personal
notes from whom the advertisers
oh really and then it was also
uncomfortable like like we would
advertise me and jackie would have to
read ads for it was always erectile
dysfunction um which is not fun to read
with your daughter it was manscape
manscape which is not fun to read she
does
she does shave me but that's we don't
want to talk about that on the air could
we cut to uh an old uh i did a manscaped
uh it was one of the first ads i had uh
uh it was during the pandemic can we cut
to one of my manscaped ads real quick
you want an ad
you send will you send jeremy hey tommy
we'll take care of this in post okay you
know before i use this razor my dick is
only this big and after using manscape
now my dick is this big
[Music]
i'm going to send it to you you'll edit
this part out i want to send you like a
20-second clip to use
and we're back i i feel like jared i
feel like jeremy has had a pretty easy
job until you come to the podcast
are you happy with how uh rick is
directing this
jeremy
yeah send all that i'll send you i'll
send you the app will you be putting it
in jeremy do you listen to everything he
says
no i don't listen no but but you will
really i want whatever he says because i
wanted to however this goes i want it to
be on rick
just send me the raw footage i'll take
care of this one
but what i really wanted to do while i
was here today and and i always forgot
when we're done with this because our
episode when you came on with uh my mom
dad and cousin teddy
which are their characters comes out um
when does this come out do you know no
when does this come out
do you know when this airs
uh maybe next tuesday but we never plan
so a week or two ago a week by the time
you're watching when does yours come out
uh it's coming out on uh next week then
then we'll make then we'll do it the
same week what day of the week does
yours come out audio only monday youtube
tuesday boy are my arms tired wednesday
is a t-shirt this will come out the same
day we'll definitely make this come out
the same day do you hear that guys
jeremy you got a lot of work to do
but i want to howie i have three ads for
that that i have to record and i was
wondering if we had time and the energy
when we're done with this i would love
to do my ads on our episode in your
studio and then we could also do
an ad for this episode
i love what you're thinking i love the
way you're okay that's what i wanted to
say it's amazing to me like after going
back and seeing you on there with the
big schlong hanging out and all the
animation you actually plan and know
this stuff either ahead of time or while
you're recording
which is amazing to me
it's uh
one of the truths
thank you yeah i'm proud of how i how
i've been doing it because i am live
editing constantly yeah and i found that
i didn't unlike you i did not see your
podcast before i was on i know you
watched ours sure but i kind of like to
be
surprised it's not it's not free yeah
you not for me what do you think i'm old
you're just you're a bubble gum buyer
yeah yeah
so i found it in golf if you've
wait he's offering money how much are
you offering
20 bucks 20 bucks he doesn't finish you
guys are all just rich huh have you ever
been on a tourniquet triple truck like i
have the floors i want you to know are
very very slippery and it's incredibly
easy to just fall right off especially
when you just wake up so don't [ __ ]
judge
i don't i even understand
like i get the interruption i get the
device but then the things you're saying
it's just here's what it is yeah
punch it up lou here's what i'm saying
i'm on a turnip truck you've never been
on a turnip truck this the floors are
very slippery so it's very easy to fall
off that's what i'm [ __ ] saying
what's a turnip truck
a turnip truck a truck that has turnips
in it no
okay so anyway
hey everyone i want you to go in the
comments and say [ __ ] no no no no
late can't take it back lots of stuff
lou has great comedic timing just needs
a different script figure out something
like that he's reading i wrote a book
it's called eight and a half seconds and
what's really interesting about this
book is it took me eight and a half
seconds to write it how often does that
happen
this was your moment man
you were going to come in and you were
going to be like hey guys i've been
working on some jokes
i spent more than eight and a half
seconds right these are stories these
are truisms yeah he doesn't tell jokes
oh you know what you're you're you're a
lazy uh hand cover it's you're too far
away with the cover rick go fly a hike
let me say it again go fly a hike
[Music]
you